so a lot of people ask me you know
alright fine I've got a Twitter account
I've got a Facebook account I've got a
blog
now what especially a lot of companies
um now what here's what I think of the
Internet as a big conference or a room
or a mixer you walk in and you start
saying hello see the funny thing is
people are scared to friend people up I
tell people start friending people go
into search dot Twitter or in teresting
in see people that say interesting
things click on them and then follow
them super be like oh isn't that like
stalking no it's like saying hello see
if people are putting stuff out there
they know that people can see it so
think of it as this companies or people
when you go on and you create these
accounts go start searching out people
that have similar interests see what I
would do is if I went to a conference I
wouldn't go to the corner and be like
this like that's six great dance people
what you do is you walk around you cut
maybe be drinking on some vino maybe was
a Jets glass and drink a little vino and
you listen like maybe just come and be
like nah man I think the Cardinals are
gonna kill the Steelers hey I'm Gary I'm
nice to meet you how are you that's what
you do in real life and the funny thing
is you have all these professionals and
all these companies that sure know how
to mingle in real life but when it comes
to the internet they want to protect
everything they want to control
everything they feel it's awkward they
don't want to stalk I get all that but
you've got to get over it cuz the
world's changed and so what you do is
once you've created of these accounts
you don't stalk you give a handshake and
you say hello and you become part of
that conversation it's not that
complicated you just gotta let it go
you're not in control you remember your
message anymore
the world controls our messages just
become part of the world see you later